[Applause]
but the difference is
is that when you're when you're awake
inside and you know yourself to
like inside out there's a you know
people always talk about manifesting
right manifesting happens in the thought
planes yeah when you sit down you think
how am i gonna get this special on
netflix
now you're manifesting this in there and
when you open your eyes you materialize
the manifestation
there's a there's a we had a guy on here
named jim quick
a great episode he's like a brain
efficiency guy and
yeah i watched it yeah so jim was i
don't know if he spoke about on the
episode but he spoke about how the guy
broke the four-minute mile
and yeah he literally manifested it yeah
and nobody had manifested it before him
yeah and once he broke it everybody
everybody broke it because it was
possible
yeah so i think the world record for
holding your breath
same thing yeah as soon as someone did
20 minutes they're like oh i guess we
did it in
yeah it's it is amazing tony hawk when
he did the uh
was it 900 miles 970 or 720
900. i'm i can't count doesn't matter so
he does the 900 and then everybody does
it so there is something interesting
about
the the power tony hawk did a 900 900
years back in the day right that was a
720 he's a legend dude wow
uh but the power of manifesting
something and believing something and
seeing something
now to take that into the ayahuasca
but the trick is to materialize it yes
so my
curiosity is is there
a time within the experience doing
ayahuasca how did you refer to it
because you didn't say the trip the
journey journey the journey of ayahuasca
where you start manifesting these things
that can be
and is that for the first time in a lot
of people's lives where they
see something and believe that it can be
real
like do people's own insecurities often
limit their happiness because they don't
even
visualize what life could be absolutely
100
100 that's like a very good ayahuasca
clip like a world-class ayahuasca clip
everyone who's about to drink ayahuasca
needs to see that that was a good one
that's the problem
because you think about things and
you're thinking like a
you're thinking like like um
like um like freaking the simpsons like
i'm manifesting but it's like they did
atari yeah and then you're manifesting
in 2d
yeah then now you're doing it
and you're in it so it's not like oh i
believe
no no no you experienced
you experienced that's the next level
past
thinking about it there's no flying
thing
it was as realized this is real let me
give you an example my first iowa yeah
so here's what happened right i'm i'm
like you know i'm a business consultant
i'm living in miami
i'm young i'm young now but i'm you know
i'm you know i've got it all figured out
i'm celebrating myself every day yeah
you know everything i'm touching turns
to gold it appears you know
and making all this money for all these
like you know hedge fund guys and i'm
getting like little bits thinking i'm
the [ __ ] yeah
you know like a little baby uh and
things go
south right not under my control just
the the system just like crumbled
i didn't know what to do my expenses
were crazy like i had
you know i was spending like way too
much per month like i had like
every i didn't know what to do right so
i
found ayahuasca when i was making a big
decision like what to do next with my
life
you know i'm going to stay here and try
something out you know when you're like
32 years old
and you need and you need to like
basically clear like 550 000
a year just to like pay for the bills
you know big nuts yeah with no college
degree like you can't just like go on
career built
yeah yeah career finder you know like so
i like one
opportunity to move to like saudi arabia
and do you know
that i was like i'm gonna trade i knew
i'm trading the hamster wheel
for the golden will but it's still a
wheel yeah but i don't want to play the
game i'm not a rat
yeah i'm not a lab mouse yeah yeah you
know i was never
in my life i was never asleep like i
studied like mysticism
religion in fifth grade i've read ten
books in my life
their religion to mysticism to ancient
history
my whole life the only thing i could
ever study and read only if i ever cared
about
was like the history of the world
spiritual paths religion
uh psychology philosophy that's all i
ever cared about
right just because i personally cared
about it right why do you think that was
well ayahuasca showed me that's the best
part okay so
i just thought it was just what i like
like some people like to paint
some people like this right i was always
in business and communication like the
process of
you know the the the art of decision
making you know like the
so i i applied this into my into
business
and so when i drink ayahuasca ayahuasca
goes oh
so you think you've just been studying
religion and all the history of the
world for no reason
i was like you know what and ayahuasca
showed me
two visions like as in like a blink
blink
blink of an eye right like right one was
i was going in front of a very large
audience like in like a
like arena stadium because of some book
i wrote
right i'm holding this book and i'm
walking out because of this book
the second vision was i'm standing over
i'm like dressed like i
in like a ceremonial outfit that i
pretty much wear now
and i'm in the i'm in the jungle
in some like temple shaking leaps on
people when they're laying down
on top of a mountain overlooking an
ocean like in the jungle
i had no idea what the hell that is
because i drank i was in miami
yeah i was in a in a high-rise
condominium in the continuum
i never even i never that was your
spiritual awakening that's the truth
that's the truth yeah
i because i know i was gonna save your
ass mother nature was like let me pluck
this [ __ ] out of here let me
i i'm [ __ ] from the nature but the
thing the truth though
i never was plugged in though that's the
thing i was never
i never had like an initial awakening i
was never really asleep
like that's the thing i never bought i
saw systems controls like religions and
stuff
yeah but i never i never subscribed i
never gave my power away
okay but i learned it all right i never
understood why i learned it it was just
because i like people and i want to
understand
you know things and i still am that way
but um i
want to show me these two visions now
this made no sense to me people were
like oh how was your sim like yeah i
don't really know like
makes no sense right so so this is
really cool
you came out of it without this
immediate knowing your purpose and
immediate change in your life like
it took a little bit because i think a
lot of people think they're gonna take
it and the second they walk out they're
like i know what my dream job is and
then i go do it that happens
that's very that's actually that's that
okay yeah yeah
i just want to set expectations that can
happen it's not a guarantee
gotcha maybe you throw up maybe you
don't 50 50.
gotcha anything that someone sells is a
is 50
maybe 50 maybe not okay okay so you you
have these two visions you walk out of
your
and real quick uh when you say ayahuasca
showed me
i'm maybe being juvenile about this but
it's not like there's a woman
with walking with you hand in hand and
taking you through this experience right
now these are these are two flashing
images you see
and then maybe some other stuff and then
you're out of there yeah like
we're talking about like it so it's like
communication without words but with
words at the same time
but as someone's talking it's like uh
are you do you have like a girlfriend
someone you're in love with beyonce okay
so when you're like in love with someone
and you're having sex
yeah right and you're having a
communication that's deeper than
imaginable right yeah even if you're not
talking just the breath
right that that times a million
inside your soul yeah yeah so there's
communication yeah yeah you know they
mean there's understandings
that don't necessarily need although at
the same time she does speak
she may materialize herself in a vision
in a personification that
that is exactly what you need like they
say that ayahuasca
has a perfect prescription for each
person that's your language
yeah yeah you're gonna get exactly what
you need she's the maestra kurandera the
master healer yeah yeah
okay like you know uh she's got the
perfect prescription for you
in this case it made no sense people
like
ayahuasca could have showed me a vision
of being the president of the united
states
that would have made more sense yeah
than any of this [ __ ]
first of all i don't how am i going to
write a book i don't read books
like you know i'm like dyslexic like i
can't even read how am i going to write
something yeah
and then uh this shaking leaves
situation in the jungle yeah made no
sense because i've never been to the
jungle
uh and but then i would go home and i
would like lay down you know at night
you have those moments like when you
wake up in the morning you look at
yourself in the eye
doesn't matter if you're a billionaire
or homeless like that's that real moment
you know
laying down and i would just be
breathing and i would breathe and i
would
revisit the vision again
and after a few nights of it just
right back to me i realized something i
realized that it doesn't matter
what it what the vision is it could have
been mechanic
shaman it could have been helping kids
whatever that is the
feeling inside of of satisfaction
of contentment of of you know what i
mean
emotional rewards yeah that was more
important
than any of the other [ __ ] that that
i could create in this wasn't the job
it was the feeling associated with it
100
and that was your purpose and that's how
you knew it was your purpose
because the feeling was right that you
and only you know
that's what i mean like that moment
before you die when you're laying in
your heart when you're laying in your
bed hopefully at home
in your castle and all and your kids and
everyone that you love is in front of
you and you say thank you thank you for
this journey
you know uh and you gracefully bow out
that last breath
yeah you know that's what you want when
you go but imagine having that breath
oh every [ __ ] day yeah every second
yeah there is a um
there's there's a if you look at you
know
some successful people or whatever they
say that a lot of like
billionaires whatever do this they start
their day with gratitude but in a weird
way they're trying
to like trick themselves into this
experience
right like they're going what am i
grateful for because they're not waking
up feeling grateful
yeah so they're going how can i
manipulate myself
into realizing all i have to be grateful
for absolutely
you're saying that is if if you live
through the thing you're supposed to do
that will organically happen absolutely
and when you're on your right path
interesting if you close your eyes right
and you say and you take attitude as
medication
yeah that's what they're doing instead
of yeah yeah okay yeah but
we make it limit we make it too linear
like yeah if you if
if you close your eyes and you inhale
through the nose
and you just let go of your frustration
ah right yeah but then you close your
eyes and you inhale and exhale gratitude
peace inside of you is the result of
just
attaching the the idea of gratitude we
have to i'm grateful for my wife
i'm grateful that i don't have i'm
grateful for my new
iphone 12. thank you thank you
you